PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome to
Build with Google Cloud, where
we build things, reference
architectures that can help you
make your Google Cloud
journey a little bit easier.
In this episode, we are going
to see how you can build
a tiny bank on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you are an
organization that wants
to either build new or
modernize traditional banking
products and solutions.
Where do you get started?
Well, stay with me to find out.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
And today, let's see
what your options
are to build a modern
digital banking
platform on Google Cloud.
Are you ready?
Let's go.
[DRILLING]
Banks were born to help
us manage our money.
Over the years, the value
provided by the bank
has expanded from checking,
savings, and personal loans,
with money transfer solutions
and bill pays and rewards.
Sadly, these solutions feel
disconnected even today.
It is time for a
simpler experience
with deeper integrations
into the bank
and each aspect
of our lives so we
don't have to carry so many
different apps on our phones
for utility, credit cards,
and to manage our budget.
Another example is it
is a common practice
for hotels and airlines
to leverage banks
to create their
own credit cards.
We should see a future
where more services can
be offered via banking
as a service model, which
is modular, cloud-native
digital bank architecture that
offers financial products
and services via APIs
and microservices.
Why modular?
Well, because value-added
services on digital platforms
enable the bank to quickly adapt
to emerging markets and demands
by measuring
success and outcomes
and can allow them to build new
products in a matter of days
and not months or years.
Now, another example
here is banks
are able to easily provide
e-commerce retailers
with a value-added service
that offers instant loans
or buy now, pay later checkout
options on their websites.
And the only way
this is possible
is with a modular architecture.
So now that we know that we
need a modular architecture,
let's see what it
takes to get there.
Here are some of
the API products
that are central to
embedded finance, which
refers to core banking
services, which
includes opening an account
or checking balance and making
payments.
But managing these API
products and services
has increased in scale,
cost, and complexity
because the legacy architecture
was a one-on-one mapping
between core banking system
and the banking front end,
such as the website.
The modern banking
as a service model
requires one-to-many mapping of
the core banking microservices
with an API layer.
This new platform enables
business transformation
by embedding and integrating
core capabilities securely
with as many new systems
and partners as needed,
such as airlines, utilities,
transportations, and telcos.
I've already dropped
some hints about how
you could start to build this
modern banking as a service
platform.
Would you like to take a shot
at some of the components
that you can start with?
Share with me in
the comments below.
OK.
So now that we know
what problem you're
solving when it comes to
modernizing retail banking,
let's see how we solve it--
time to dive into the high-level
components that we need.
A modern digital bank comprises
of multiple business functions
and capabilities.
These logical components
can be organized
into a few high-level
categories.
Let's consider a fictitious
financial institution,
Symbol Bank.
It has to have services
across various channels
to serve the external customers.
These could include
applications that directly
serve the customers-- the
payments, the operation
services for onboarding,
management, servicing, and then
the partner services.
Then comes the
integration services,
which act as the
interoperability and
connectivity layer for
all the bank's services
and applications--
essentially, the
technology glue that
brings the core platform
data and various applications
together to orchestrate
and provide a business
function for the
bank to its users.
Then there are the data
applications and platform,
which include the various
data pipelines-- streaming,
processing, governance,
and data warehousing
for applications and services.
The enterprise
application services
make up the enterprise
back office services
that keep the business
operating and compliant.
Well, these include various
foundational components
of the bank, like finance
and treasury, financial ERP,
the governance,
risk, and control,
the regulatory reporting,
and audit and compliance.
Now, core application services
are those core services
and applications and data
that are required for a bank
to offer products and
services to their customers.
These include the
core banking data
models for sensitive customer
information, transactions,
products, and things like that
as well as all the processing
and persistence of that data.
Now, additional core services
include card management,
payments, collections, and
credit and fraud risks.
Then there are the
infrastructure operations
and security components that
apply to all functional aspects
of the bank's capabilities.
These are considered
foundational components
to ensure the bank's customer
data, integrity, and privacy
with appropriate
controls and policies
that adhere to the
bank's internal controls
and government regulations.
Now that we know what
capabilities a bank
needs or offers, we
are ready to dive
into the architecture
to make this work.
Well, in this part
of the video, we
are going to look at each of the
segments of the retail banking,
one by one, from channel
services, integration services,
data applications and platforms,
enterprise application
services, core application
services, and infrastructure,
security, and operations.
Channel services include
services for customer channels,
such as banking and
customer services,
using Contact Center
AI and messaging.
Transaction channels, such
as credit and debit payments
using Google Pay,
and partner channels,
which is connecting
with open banking
APIs and other marketplaces
using Apigee API Gateway--
now, these services power
the customer applications,
such as the ones needed
for operations, onboarding,
management, servicing
the customer,
showing customers the right
ads, sales, marketing,
and loyalty apps.
Then you have the
integration layer,
which comprises the API
connectors on Apigee API
Management.
These connectors take
the real-time and batch
unstructured and structured
data and then pass it
on to the data science
layer for further analysis
and creating unique user
experiences, like personalized
recommendations and
propensity models,
or preventing financial
crime with fraud prediction
and anomaly detection
with Vertex AI platform.
You can also run
high-performance computing
workloads using Tensor
GPUs within Vertex AI.
In addition, Vertex AI
streamlines the IML pipelines
and provides explainable AI
outputs and model governance.
Now, Event and
Transformation Hub
also ingests the batch
data through Cloud Storage
and real-time data through
Pub/Sub messaging service
and passes it on to data
flow for transformation
and orchestration.
The processed data is then sent
to serverless data warehouse,
BigQuery, and metadata that is
stored in Cloud Storage, which
is a data lake.
Other teams and
applications can then
access this data through
a unified data management
catalog, Dataplex.
As you can see,
the data platform
enables the bank to
securely process and store
sensitive customer data while
enriching with additional data
sets to gain a
better understanding
of their customers and products.
Then comes the enterprise
application services
that make up the
back office services,
which keep the business
operating and compliant.
And these include various
foundational components
of the bank, like finance
and treasury, financial ERP,
visualizations, regulatory
reporting, audits, compliance,
governance, risk, and control.
We query the data of
a BigQuery and then
use it to generate
visualizations in Looker.
Core application services
are the core services
that are required for a
bank to offer its products
and services to the customers.
Now, these services
are typically
deployed as microservices
on Kubernetes Engine
with transaction, products, and
customer data on Cloud Spanner.
Event-driven microservices
communicate with each other
using Cloud Pub/Sub.
Additional core services
include card management
and payments and collections
and credit and fraud risk.
Then there are the core security
and operational components
that apply to all the
functional aspects of the bank's
capabilities.
Now, these services include
identity and access management
for authentication and
authorization standards, data
locality, encryption and key
management, data anonymization
and tokenization, along
with system, network,
and application logs for access
transparency and monitoring
incidents and SLAs.
I know, I know, that was a lot.
But don't worry.
I've linked a sample
application code for you
that you can run as your
own bank on Google Cloud.
Click and learn how it works.
And don't forget to share
how it went for you.
We just looked at a
reference architecture
to build a digital
banking platform
on Google Cloud, the different
components and Google Cloud
Services that you can use
to build those components
or augment them.
Wherever you start, it'll
be a success and great start
to gain agility in launching
new features, innovation,
and improving
customer experience
while keeping the data safe
and using it to gain insights.
Now it's your turn.
Go build a tiny
digital bank using
the documentation and full
sample code repository linked
below.
If you liked this
video, then I encourage
you to let me know by clicking
on the Like and Subscribe
buttons.
Oh, and if you want to see me
built a specific architecture
in this series, let me
know in the comments below.
I cannot wait to build
more stuff with you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]